il est bel homme genre non via quel âge
ou le claret bien moi y'a pas toi
elle a du caractère t'as faim tu sais
que tu veux dire savage par vidéo
je parle bien écoute l ai fait lire
madame de bovary elle va me quitter
la virée du lit puis de moi je dors dans
le salon comme un chien et
bourg-saint-maurice mais je sais bien
qu'elle te trompes
tout le monde est au courant ya que toi
oui je sais je les cordes on a alors
et qu'est ce que tu attends fait quelque
chose me bats toi merde
au début je me disais que ça durerait
pas on est un couple c'est ça que je
pensais c'est ça qui compte maintenant
maintenant à toi je m'en fous c'est
comme si ça n'existe pas peux me tromper
avec toute la cellule si elle veut tu
veux que je fasse plus beau gosse fait
lui un gosse je te dis avec 1go 7
quittera pas moi j'ai compris ça avec la
petite jouait les lie c'est comme si là
où s'était dégagée maintenant non c'est
tout moi